I join McCormick being the acting
returning officer at the election of the
Member of Parliament for thrombin year
to hereby give notice that the number of
votes recorded for each candidate at the
said election is as follows Luke
Anthony Hall the Conservative Party
candidate twenty eight thousand and
eight votes Ian Adams Hamilton the Green
Party candidate six hundred and thirty
three votes Brown Peter made Libra party
candidate 6112 votes Claire Louise young
Liberal Democrats fifteen thousand nine
hundred and thirty seven votes the
number of ballot papers rejected was as
follows folding four more candidates
than the voter was entitled to fifteen
be known marked or wholly void from
certainty 86 giving a total of rejected
ballots of 101 and I do hereby declare
that Luke Anthony whole is duly elected
[Applause]
thank you thank you I would start by
thanking our police and security
services for keeping this most valuable
of democratic institutions safe across
the country today especially in the
climates over the last few weeks but
also to thank the returning officer and
all of the council staff here tonight
for such a professional accurate and
timely result and also thank the other
candidates putting yourself forward for
election and open yourself up to
scrutiny is a difficult experience and
having the range of candidates we had
gave the people of thorn Green Yeats a
genuine choice it has been the greatest
honor of my life to represent this
wonderful constituency I live in the 8th
and was born and grew up in south
ossetia and I am delighted to thank the
voters of Thornbury Yates and all the
surrounding towns villages and hamlets
for giving me the opportunity to serve
them again and for this remarkable
result which I'm humbled by I would also
like to thank my fantastic campaign to
who open with me all the way there are
too many people to name individually but
I'd like to single out Owen evidence for
his remarkable dedication our work and
skill
[Applause]
I'd also like to thank my agents on your
Williams and all the volunteers who have
worked so hard during this campaign I
also want to thank my wife Roisin who
helped me fight this campaign most
pregnant and thank you for all of your
support I try to finish by saying to all
of my constituents that whoever you
voted for I'm here as the local MP to
serve everything and to act as your
Member of Parliament and I hope in the
years to come I can serve you all and do
you all proud
thank you so much
[Applause]